Summer is on its way to our listeners in the Northern Hemisphere. One of the best things about summer is getting to do all your favourite indoor things outside. Sharing meals, having a barbecue, chatting with friends. Everything is better Ralph Fresco. Articles curated catalogue of outdoor furniture is here to help you venture outdoors this summer. They've got everything you need to really make things your own, from outdoor sofas to dining sets to decor. Article believes in delightful design for every home,
对于北半球的听众来说，夏天即将来临。夏天最棒的事情之一就是把所有你喜欢的室内活动搬到户外去做。分享美食、烧烤、与朋友聊天。一切都变得更美好了。Article精心挑选的户外家具系列旨在帮助您在这个夏天走向户外。从户外沙发、餐桌椅到装饰品，他们拥有您真正打造个性化空间所需的一切。Article相信每个家都应该拥有令人愉悦的设计，
and thanks to their online-only model, they have some really delightful prices too. Case file team member Atavia recently ordered a couch from Article. She loved how easy it was to choose and order from Article's user-friendly website, and when the couch arrived, Atavia was really impressed with the quality wood and materials. The delivery process was seamless and the Article team communicated throughout. Atavia loves how her new couch looks in her space. Article is offering our listeners $50 off your first purchase of $100 or more. To claim, visit article.com forward slash case file,
而且得益于他们纯线上的销售模式，他们的价格也非常令人愉悦。案件档案团队成员Atavia最近从Article订购了一张沙发。她非常喜欢Article用户友好型网站带来的便捷选择和订购体验，当沙发送达时，Atavia对优质的木材和材料印象深刻。配送过程非常顺畅，Article团队全程保持沟通。Atavia非常喜欢她的新沙发在空间里的样子。Article为我们的听众提供首单满100美元立减50美元的优惠。如需领取，请访问article.com斜杠casefile，
and the discount will be automatically applied at checkout. That's a-r-t-i-c-l-e dot com forward slash case file for $50 off your first purchase of $100 or more. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners.
折扣将在结账时自动应用。网址是a-r-t-i-c-l-e点com斜杠casefile，首单满100美元立减50美元。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。今天的剧集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。
On the night of Sunday, September 5, 1982, the crew aboard a fishing vessel called The Decade threw a party. They were celebrating the coming end of the fishing season. While they drank inside their boat, a storm raged across the Southern Alaskan coast outside. At around six the following morning, a hungover crew member stuck it out to the deck to be sick over the side. The sun was breaking over the misty horizon as rain drizzled across the cold blue waters of the Pacific. The crew member took in his surroundings and caught sight of something. Another fishing vessel, a 58-foot purse sena dubbed to the investor, was slowly drifting out to sea.
1982年9月5日星期日晚上，一艘名为“十年号”（The Decade）的渔船上的船员们举办了一场派对。他们正在庆祝捕鱼季即将结束。当他们在船舱内喝酒时，船外的阿拉斯加南部海岸正狂风暴雨。次日清晨六点左右，一名宿醉的船员来到甲板上，在船舷边呕吐。太阳正从雾蒙蒙的地平线上升起，细雨飘落在太平洋冰冷的蓝色水面上。这名船员环顾四周，突然看到了什么。另一艘渔船，一艘名为“投资者号”（The Investor）的58英尺围网渔船，正缓慢地向海上漂去。
Barely visible in the gloomy weather was the investor's pilot house, where its navigation equipment was held. At the helm was a man. He looked to be in his 20s and was of average height with a stocky build. He was wearing a baseball cap, though some of his light-colored hair was visible. The final phase of the salmon season was being reopened by Alaska's Department of Fish and Game that day. It seemed the investor was getting a head start. The man behind the wheel was assumed to be the investor's captain, 28-year-old Mark Colterst. The decade crew member waved to him. The man raised a single hand in response
在阴沉的天气里，几乎看不清“投资者号”的驾驶室，那里存放着导航设备。掌舵的是一名男子。他看起来20多岁，中等身材，体格健壮。他戴着一顶棒球帽，但仍能看到一些浅色的头发。阿拉斯加州渔猎部当天重新开放了鲑鱼捕捞季的最后阶段。看起来“投资者号”是想抢占先机。掌舵的男子被认为是“投资者号”的船长，28岁的马克·科尔瑟斯特（Mark Colthurst）。“十年号”的船员向他挥手。那名男子举起一只手作为回应，
as he steered the investor silently away. Throughout mid to late 1982, dozens of fishing trawlers were docked in the remote Alaskan village of Craig. Located on Prince of Wales Island in the southern part of the state, Craig faces outwards to the Gulf of Alaska, with several other smaller, largely deserted islands inside. The local community of just 600 people relied on its strong fishing industry, supported by the abundance of halibut and salmon in the surrounding waters. Craig was a stopping point for fishing vessels as they journeyed between Alaska and the continental United States. Boats docked at the village overnight, then set sail shortly before
随后默默地驾驶着“投资者号”离开了。1982年中后期，数十艘拖网渔船停靠在阿拉斯加偏远的克雷格（Craig）村。克雷格位于该州南部的威尔士亲王岛上，面向阿拉斯加湾，岛内还有其他几个较小的、基本荒无人烟的岛屿。当地仅有的600名居民依靠强大的渔业为生，周围水域丰富的比目鱼和鲑鱼为他们提供了支持。克雷格是渔船往返于阿拉斯加和美国大陆之间的中转站。船只在村里过夜停靠，然后在临近
first delight in search of a fishery, areas of sea where fish are caught in large quantities. Captains and their crews were known to anchor at a fishery for several days before returning to Craig to sell their catch. The fish were then sent to the island's cold storage plant and cannery. The investor was one of the more impressive boats docked in Craig. The state of the art red and grey fiberglass sena was the largest size of boat permitted to fish in Alaskan waters. Valued at around $1.5 million, the vessel was comfortable to live in and decked out with the latest fishing gear. The investor was just one year old when its current captain, Mark Colterst, boarded. Mark was a naturally gifted fisherman from the state of Washington.
黎明时分启航，寻找渔场，即大量捕鱼的海域。船长和船员们通常会在渔场抛锚几天，然后再回到克雷格出售渔获。鱼随后被送到岛上的冷藏厂和罐头厂。在克雷格停靠的船只中，“投资者号”是比较引人注目的一艘。这艘最先进的红灰色玻璃钢围网渔船是阿拉斯加水域允许捕鱼的最大尺寸船只。该船价值约150万美元，居住舒适，并配备了最新的捕鱼设备。当现任船长马克·科尔瑟斯特登船时，“投资者号”才一岁。马克是一位来自华盛顿州的天赋异禀的渔民。
He had taken up fishing in his teens, starting out with a wooden skiff he used to net herring for profit. He then upgraded to an old rusted trawler. During a week-long expedition in 1979, Mark hauled in an impressive $105,000 worth of fish. Eventually, he bought the boat of his dreams, the investor. In a feature article for Pacific Fisherman magazine, Mark explained that he had named the investor after the money he was certain it would make. He hoped it would facilitate his plans to retire at the age of 50. In 1982, Mark arrived in Craig on Sunday, September 5, after two weeks at sea. It was a rare stop. He didn't usually visit the island village. It was also the first time he'd been there in his new boat. A broom was attached to
他十几岁时就开始捕鱼，最初用一艘木制小艇捕捞鲱鱼获利。后来他升级到了一艘生锈的旧拖网渔船。在1979年为期一周的远征中，马克捕获了价值105,000美元的鱼，成绩斐然。最终，他买下了梦想中的船——“投资者号”。在《太平洋渔民》杂志的一篇专题文章中，马克解释说，他以这艘船肯定能赚到的钱为它命名。他希望这能帮助他实现50岁退休的计划。1982年9月5日星期日，马克在海上航行两周后抵达克雷格。这是一个罕见的停靠点。他通常不会访问这个岛村。这也是他第一次驾驶新船来到这里。一根扫帚被系在
the investor's mast, a message to other vessels that it had so far caught 100,000 pounds of salmon. Because there weren't enough moorage spots on Craig's dock to accommodate so many boats, the investor was tethered to the Decade, which was tied to another boat called the Defiant. In the early hours of Monday, September 6, the investor was on the move. Aside from the hungover crew member aboard the Decade, a number of other fishermen noticed the investor quietly slipping away. Mike Colterst had left the investor's tie lines, the heavy braided rope that had connected it to the Decade, on the other boat's deck. Tie lines cost over $100. They were not the type of thing fishermen discarded lightly.
“投资者号”的桅杆上，向其他船只传达它目前已捕获10万磅鲑鱼的信息。由于克雷格码头的泊位不足以容纳这么多船只，“投资者号”被系在“十年号”上，而“十年号”又系在另一艘名为“挑衅号”（The Defiant）的船上。9月6日星期一凌晨，“投资者号”开始移动。除了“十年号”上那名宿醉的船员外，还有其他几名渔民注意到“投资者号”悄悄溜走了。迈克·科尔瑟斯特将“投资者号”的系泊缆绳——连接它与“十年号”的粗编织绳——留在了另一艘船的甲板上。系泊缆绳价值超过100美元。这不是渔民会轻易丢弃的东西。
At around 7.30am, it stopped at Fish Air Island, a small landmass about a mile away. Then a heavy fog rolled in, obscuring the investor from sight. The fog hung low across the harbour for the rest of the day. It finally cleared by the following morning of Tuesday, September 7, revealing that the investor hadn't moved from its spot alongside Fish Air Island. Just after 4pm that day, fishermen Bruce Anderson noticed thick black smoke by Fish Air Island. He wondered whether it was engine exhaust from a vessel that had just started its motor. The smoke remained heavy and didn't dissipate. Bruce grew concerned and grabbed a pair of binoculars. He recognised the investor.
早上7点30分左右，它在约一英里外的一个小陆块——鱼空气岛（Fish Egg Island）停了下来。随后大雾弥漫，遮住了“投资者号”的身影。大雾在港口上空笼罩了整整一天。直到次日9月7日星期二清晨，雾气终于散去，显示“投资者号”并没有离开鱼空气岛旁的位置。当天下午4点刚过，渔民布鲁斯·安德森（Bruce Anderson）注意到鱼空气岛附近有浓浓的黑烟。他怀疑那是刚启动引擎的船只排出的废气。烟雾依然浓重，没有消散。布鲁斯感到担忧，拿起双筒望远镜。他认出了“投资者号”。
It was engulfed in flames. Bruce and his wife, Jan Kittleson, raced towards the fire in their own boat. As they drew closer, they saw a smaller boat speeding towards them from the investor's direction. It was a 20ft red and grey fiberglass skiff, a craft used to manoeuvre a purse seen as fishing net into place before the net is pulled on board. Bruce and Jan identified the skiff as belonging to the investor, as it was made of the same fiberglass and painted to match the larger vessel. But they didn't recognise the lone man in it. He had tanned skin and slightly long hair, partially obscured by a baseball cap. Bruce thought he had a California surfer look about him.
它被火焰吞没了。布鲁斯和他的妻子简·基特尔森（Jan Kittleson）驾驶自己的船冲向火场。当他们靠近时，看到一艘较小的船正从“投资者号”的方向向他们疾驰而来。那是一艘20英尺长的红灰色玻璃钢小艇，这种船用于在围网被拉上船之前，将围网引导到位。布鲁斯和简认出这艘小艇属于“投资者号”，因为它是由同样的玻璃钢制成，且漆色与大船相匹配。但他们不认识艇上那名孤身一人的男子。他皮肤黝黑，头发稍长，被一顶棒球帽遮住了一部分。布鲁斯觉得他看起来像个加州冲浪者。
Jan waved for the man to stop, but he seemed determined to avoid them. Bruce cut the skiff off, forcing the man to stop about 15ft away. Are there people on the boat? Jan shouted. The man didn't reply. Jan repeated herself several times. Wide-eyed, the man finally said, Yes, there are people on the boat. He then sped off at full throttle towards Craig. Sue Dominovsky and her boyfriend Paul Page were watching the chaos unfolding from the docks in Craig.
简挥手示意那名男子停下，但他似乎执意要避开他们。布鲁斯截住了小艇，迫使那名男子在约15英尺外停下。“船上有人吗？”简大喊道。那名男子没有回答。简重复了几遍。那名男子瞪大眼睛，终于说道：“是的，船上有人。”随后他全速向克雷格方向疾驰而去。苏·多米诺夫斯基（Sue Dominovsky）和她的男友保罗·佩奇（Paul Page）正在克雷格的码头上看着混乱的场面。
It seemed like every boat in town was moving towards the fire, except one. A man in a red and grey fiberglass skiff was heading to shore. He looked about 20 or 21 years old and roughly 150lbs. He had brown or blonde hair, and was wearing a baseball cap with a logo on it. What was striking was how unbothered the man looked, as if nothing out of the ordinary was happening. He was driving at such rapid speed, he caused waves that flooded the engine of a passing rescue party. The man landed the skiff with a crash, hitting its bow into the dock, that Sue Dominovsky was standing on. She felt a shake beneath her feet.
似乎镇上所有的船都在向火场移动，只有一艘例外。一名驾驶红灰色玻璃钢小艇的男子正向岸边驶去。他看起来大约20或21岁，体重约150磅。他留着棕色或金色的头发，戴着一顶印有标志的棒球帽。令人震惊的是，这名男子看起来如此镇定，仿佛什么异常的事情都没有发生。他驾驶的速度极快，激起的波浪淹没了路过救援船只的引擎。那名男子猛地靠岸，船头撞上了苏·多米诺夫斯基所站的码头。她感到脚下一阵震动。
The young man leapt from the skiff, and hurriedly tied it to the dock. His face was pale, but his cheeks appeared slightly flushed. He carried what looked like a shoebox under one arm. Sue and her boyfriend Paul asked if the man had come from Craig's home. He came from the boat that was burning. No, he replied, before explaining that he was in a hurry. He fidgeted awkwardly, and kept his gaze downcast. Sue then asked if there was anyone on the burning boat.
那名年轻人从艇上跳下，匆忙将它系在码头上。他的脸色苍白，但脸颊似乎微微泛红。他的一只胳膊下夹着一个看起来像鞋盒的东西。苏和她的男友保罗问那名男子是否来自克雷格的家。“他来自那艘着火的船。”“不，”他回答道，随后解释说他很赶时间。他局促不安，目光低垂。苏随后问着火的船上是否还有人。
It was hard to get a clear answer. The man spoke slowly, as though in shock. He reiterated that he had to go, yet he just remained standing there. He offered the couple use of his skiff, before saying that he had to go call the Coast Guard. No one's called the Coast Guard yet? Sue cried out in surprise. The man walked away without a reply. The fire was fierce, producing waves of heat so intense it was impossible to move in to stop it. It consumed the investor's wheelhouse and spread along the back deck. A smaller, more nimble vessel circled closer to the investor to see if anyone was on board.
很难得到明确的回答。那名男子说话很慢，仿佛处于震惊之中。他重申他必须走了，但他只是站在那里。他提出让这对夫妇使用他的小艇，然后说他必须去给海岸警卫队打电话。“还没人给海岸警卫队打电话吗？”苏惊讶地喊道。那名男子没有回答就走开了。火势凶猛，产生的热浪极其强烈，根本无法靠近扑灭。它吞噬了“投资者号”的驾驶室，并蔓延到后甲板。一艘更小、更灵活的船只绕着“投资者号”靠近，查看船上是否有人。
Nothing was visible, aside from a few unidentifiable objects bobbing in the water. With no way to get close enough to douse the flames, onlookers watched helplessly. At 4.20pm, Alaska State Trooper Bob Anderson was alerted to the situation. He took his personal boat to Fishag Island, where a small fleet surrounded the investor from a safe distance. By now, the investor's entire cabin, galley, bridge and scene net were ablaze. The speed and viciousness of the fire left Trooper Anderson in no doubt. It had been deliberately lit. Trooper Anderson rushed back to Craig to locate the investor's captain.
除了水面上漂浮着一些无法辨认的物体外，什么也看不见。由于无法靠近灭火，围观者只能无助地看着。下午4点20分，阿拉斯加州警官鲍勃·安德森（Bob Anderson）接到警报。他驾驶自己的船前往鱼空气岛，那里有一小支船队在安全距离外包围了“投资者号”。此时，“投资者号”的整个船舱、厨房、舰桥和围网都在燃烧。火势的速度和凶猛程度让安德森警官毫不怀疑：这是蓄意纵火。安德森警官赶回克雷格寻找“投资者号”的船长。
He was informed that Mark Colterst hadn't been fishing alone that season. He was joined by four deckhands, 18-year-old Chris Heyman and Mike Stewart, Dean Moon and Jerome Cowan, who were all 19. Also travelling aboard the investor were Mark's wife Irene and their two children, 5-year-old Kimberly and 4-year-old John. Irene was 3 months pregnant. Trooper Anderson got to work tracking down everyone who had been on the investor. The last time the Coltersts and their crew had been seen was two days earlier, on Sunday, September 5. That afternoon, Mark and his deckhands returned to Craig to offload salmon they'd caught. Payment wouldn't come through until the following day.
他被告知马克·科尔瑟斯特那个捕鱼季并不是独自一人。随行的还有四名甲板工：18岁的克里斯·海曼（Chris Heyman）和迈克·斯图尔特（Mike Stewart），以及19岁的迪恩·穆恩（Dean Moon）和杰罗姆·考恩（Jerome Cowan）。随“投资者号”旅行的还有马克的妻子艾琳（Irene）和他们的两个孩子：5岁的金伯利（Kimberly）和4岁的约翰（John）。艾琳当时已怀孕3个月。安德森警官开始着手追踪所有在“投资者号”上的人。科尔瑟斯特一家及其船员最后一次露面是在两天前的9月5日星期日。那天下午，马克和他的甲板工回到克雷格卸下捕获的鲑鱼。报酬要到第二天才能到账。
Faced with some spare time, Mark gave his crew the night off. Dean Moon and Jerome Cowan headed into town. Chris Heyman and Mike Stewart weren't seen with them. It was presumed they remained behind on the investor. Mark Colterst opted to spend the night with his wife and children. It was the family's last chance to be together for a while. Irene, Kimberly and John were flying back to Washington the next day to prepare for Kimberly's starting school. September 5 also happened to be Mark's 28th birthday. The Coltersts had a celebratory dinner at a local restaurant before returning to the investor just before 10 o'clock.
由于有空闲时间，马克给船员们放了一晚假。迪恩·穆恩和杰罗姆·考恩进了城。克里斯·海曼和迈克·斯图尔特没有和他们一起出现。人们推测他们留在了“投资者号”上。马克·科尔瑟斯特选择与妻子和孩子们共度夜晚。这是这家人一段时间内最后一次团聚的机会。艾琳、金伯利和约翰第二天就要飞回华盛顿，为金伯利上学做准备。9月5日恰好也是马克的28岁生日。科尔瑟斯特一家在当地一家餐馆吃了庆祝晚餐，然后在10点前回到“投资者号”。
They were witnessed clamouring over the two boats the investor was tethered to, passing a party in full swing along the way. No one from the investor was sighted after that night. At 8pm, State Trooper Bob Anderson received a call that the fire had been extinguished. The once gleaming investor was now a charred and melted wreck. Trooper Anderson boarded the ruined boat. It was slick from water and leaning slightly to the right, making it difficult to walk on. Where the galley door had once stood was what appeared to be the badly burnt carcass of an animal, perhaps a dog lying on its side with its legs sticking out. On closer inspection, Trooper Anderson realised the corpse was actually human.
有人目击他们爬过“投资者号”系泊的两艘船，途中经过了一场正在进行的派对。那天晚上之后，再也没有人见过“投资者号”上的人。晚上8点，州警官鲍勃·安德森接到电话，称火已被扑灭。曾经闪闪发光的“投资者号”现在成了一堆烧焦融化的残骸。安德森警官登上了这艘破损的船。船上满是水，略微向右倾斜，走起来很困难。曾经是厨房门的地方，出现了一具看起来像是被严重烧焦的动物尸体，也许是一条狗侧卧着，腿伸了出来。仔细检查后，安德森警官意识到这具尸体实际上是人类的。
Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada, so the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to net zero. Investing in technology and innovation already cut emissions an average 22 per barrel, working with governments to create and protect jobs, developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our net zero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content.
案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。油砂作业在加拿大造成了大量的碳排放，因此六家最大的公司联手在实现净零排放的道路上迈进。投资技术和创新已经使每桶排放量平均减少了22%，与政府合作创造和保护就业机会，并开发了世界上最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正在多条路径上取得进展。请在pathwaysalliance.ca查看我们的行动计划。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持案件档案继续提供高质量的内容。
Dental records confirmed the body belonged to 19-year-old Deckhand Mike Stewart. He was also Captain Mark Colthurst's cousin. Mike's remains were too destroyed to determine a cause of death. A second body was soon discovered beneath a section of melted fiberglass where the investor's stateroom had been. This one was tiny. It was five-year-old Kimberly, the oldest of the two Colthurst children. While Kimberly's body was also too damaged to determine a cause of death, there was evidence that she might have been bludgeoned. Another two bodies were found under a separate layer of fiberglass. One was on top of the other. The body on top was Mark Colthurst. Under him was Irene Colthurst.
牙科记录证实，这具尸体属于19岁的甲板工迈克·斯图尔特。他也是马克·科尔瑟斯特船长的表弟。迈克的遗体损毁严重，无法确定死因。不久后，在“投资者号”特等舱原址的一块融化的玻璃钢下发现了第二具尸体。这具尸体很小。她是5岁的金伯利，科尔瑟斯特两个孩子中较大的一个。虽然金伯利的尸体也损毁严重，无法确定死因，但有证据表明她可能遭到过钝器击打。在另一层玻璃钢下又发现了两具尸体。一具叠在另一具上面。上面的尸体是马克·科尔瑟斯特。在他下面的是艾琳·科尔瑟斯特。
It appeared Mark had died while protecting his pregnant wife. Both had been shot multiple times, including at least once in the head. As Mark, Irene, Kimberly and Mike's remains were being collected, the fire broke out again. The first responders were forced to disembark as firefighting efforts resumed. It took until the following night of Wednesday, September 8 to put the fire out for good. What remained of the investor was towed to shore. A device that detects accelerants uncovered traces of pure white gasoline on the wreckage. White gasoline is primarily used in camp stoves and lanterns.
看起来马克是在保护怀孕的妻子时遇害的。两人都曾多次中枪，包括头部至少中了一枪。当马克、艾琳、金伯利和迈克的遗体被收集时，火势再次爆发。急救人员被迫撤离，灭火工作重新开始。直到次日9月8日星期三晚上，火势才被彻底扑灭。“投资者号”的残骸被拖回岸边。一种探测助燃剂的装置在残骸上发现了纯白汽油的痕迹。白汽油主要用于露营炉和灯笼。
Its presence on the investor confirmed that the fire was the result of arson. A burnt Ruger Mini-14 semi-automatic rifle was also recovered in the wreckage. This was an unexpected find. Mark and Irene Colthurst had been executed with a .22 caliber firearm. Its specifics are known. This meant the murder weapon was still missing. Between 5 and 7 pounds of bone fragments were found where the decans slept. A partial jaw bone belonged to 19-year-old Jerome Cowan. The remaining bones couldn't be identified.
它在“投资者号”上的存在证实了火灾是纵火的结果。残骸中还发现了一支烧焦的鲁格Mini-14半自动步枪。这是一个意想不到的发现。马克和艾琳·科尔瑟斯特是被.22口径的枪支处决的。其具体型号已知。这意味着凶器仍然下落不明。在“十年号”船员睡觉的地方发现了5到7磅的骨头碎片。一块部分颌骨属于19岁的杰罗姆·考恩。其余的骨头无法辨认。
It was possible they belonged to one or both of the remaining decans, 19-year-old Dean Moon and 18-year-old Chris Heyman. No trace of the Colthurst's youngest child, 4-year-old John Colthurst, was found. Investigators considered the possibility that he'd been taken from the vessel, but it seemed more likely that his body had been entirely lost to the fire. The fact that the blaze had melted the fiberglass vessel was indicative of its extremely high temperature. John was known to sleep on a daybed in the wheelhouse where the fire might have been lit. Investigators suspected that all the victims were shot and killed beforehand.
它们有可能属于剩下的两名“十年号”船员中的一人或两人，即19岁的迪恩·穆恩和18岁的克里斯·海曼。没有发现科尔瑟斯特家最小的孩子，4岁的约翰·科尔瑟斯特的踪迹。调查人员考虑过他可能被从船上带走的可能性，但他的尸体在火灾中完全消失的可能性似乎更大。火灾融化了玻璃钢船体这一事实表明火灾温度极高。众所周知，约翰睡在驾驶室的日间床上，而火可能就是从那里点燃的。调查人员怀疑所有受害者都是事先被枪杀的。
Kimberley and the decans were killed in their beds with the exception of Jerome Cowan. The location of his remains suggested he'd been by the galley door when he died, as though heading out to the deck. Perhaps he'd been trying to escape. No one aboard the Investor was seen after the evening of Sunday, September 5, meaning they were likely killed that night. In order to reach the Investor, the killer had to walk across two other boats, the Decade and the Defiant. It was possible they hadn't been noticed due to the raucous parties taking place on both vessels. The gunshots could have been drowned out by the noise.
金伯利和“十年号”船员是在床上被杀的，杰罗姆·考恩除外。他遗体的位置表明他死时正在厨房门口，仿佛正要走向甲板。也许他当时正试图逃跑。9月5日星期日晚上之后，再也没有人见过“投资者号”上的人，这意味着他们很可能是在那天晚上被杀的。为了到达“投资者号”，凶手必须穿过另外两艘船，“十年号”和“挑衅号”。由于两艘船上都在举行喧闹的派对，他们可能没有被注意到。枪声可能被噪音掩盖了。
The Investor was witness to drifting away at dawn the next day with an unidentified man behind the steering wheel. He was using the vessel's far quieter auxiliary motor, likely to avoid attention. Upon reaching Fishag Island, it was believed the killer tried to sink the Investor by opening the engine rooms of valves. Dense fog concealed the vessel for the remainder of the day. When it cleared, the killer would have seen the Investor was still afloat. Mark Colthurst was so safety conscious he had filled the hull of the Investor with flotation material. Realizing his initial plan had failed, the killer returned to the boat and set it ablaze. Craig was reeling in the wake of such a violent crime. Rumors spread, with many
“投资者号”被目击在次日黎明漂走，掌舵的是一名身份不明的男子。他使用的是该船声音小得多的辅助引擎，很可能是为了避免引起注意。到达鱼空气岛后，人们认为凶手试图通过打开引擎室的阀门来沉没“投资者号”。浓雾掩盖了这艘船整整一天。当雾散去时，凶手会发现“投资者号”仍然漂浮着。马克·科尔瑟斯特非常有安全意识，他在“投资者号”的船体内填充了浮力材料。意识到最初的计划失败后，凶手回到船上并放火焚烧。克雷格在如此暴力的犯罪后陷入了恐慌。谣言四起，许多人
claiming to know who was responsible. Mark didn't store cash on his boat, ruling out the likelihood it was a robbery gone wrong. Some believed it was the work of Alaska native fishermen furious about the large-scale fishing by outsiders. Others theorized that a float plane had flown the killers away from the scene under the cover of night. It was also speculated that four-year-old John Colthurst, whose body was never found, had been kidnapped. John was a friendly child who stopped in on other boats to say hello during his family's brief time in Craig. He'd often tell people that he wanted to be a fisherman like his dad, had the chatty and independent John fallen victim to a predator.
声称知道是谁干的。马克不在船上存放现金，排除了抢劫失败的可能性。有些人认为这是阿拉斯加原住民渔民所为，他们对局外人的大规模捕鱼感到愤怒。其他人则推测，一架水上飞机在夜幕掩护下将凶手带离了现场。还有人猜测，尸体从未被发现的4岁约翰·科尔瑟斯特被绑架了。约翰是一个友好的孩子，在他们一家在克雷格短暂逗留期间，他会去其他船上打招呼。他经常告诉人们他想成为像他爸爸一样的渔民，健谈而独立的约翰难道成了掠食者的受害者吗？
One day, state troopers received a call from a man asking for information. He wanted addresses for relatives of missing Investor crew member Chris Heyman and little John Colthurst. The man knew detailed information about the Investor crime scene, including where some of the bodies were found. He then dropped a bombshell. Chris Heyman and John Colthurst were alive. He had helped them escape and had driven them back to Washington. This call was traced to Goshen, a town in the Midwest state of Indiana. The phone number led to a man who identified himself as T-Rex Mullins. When asked what the T stood for, the man replied, Tyranosaurus.
一天，州警官接到一个男子的电话，询问信息。他想要失踪的“投资者号”船员克里斯·海曼和小约翰·科尔瑟斯特亲属的地址。该男子知道关于“投资者号”犯罪现场的详细信息，包括一些尸体被发现的位置。随后他抛出了一个重磅炸弹。克里斯·海曼和约翰·科尔瑟斯特还活着。他帮助他们逃脱，并开车把他们送回了华盛顿。这个电话被追踪到中西部印第安纳州的戈申（Goshen）镇。电话号码指向一个自称T-Rex穆林斯（T-Rex Mullins）的男子。当被问及T代表什么时，该男子回答：“霸王龙”（Tyranosaurus）。
T-Rex was questioned for two hours. Initially, his story about Chris Heyman and John Colthurst's survival seemed credible. Then, he described the route he'd driven the pair through Alaska. It was completely at odds with the state's geography. Troopers charged T-Rex with filing a false report. He said that if the police wanted further evidence, they should check beneath the sofa cushion in his house. They did and discovered a sensationalist true crime magazine. It featured an article titled Mystery of the Sailing Skeletons that contained lots of details about the Investor murders. Law enforcement hadn't realized that this information had somehow been
T-Rex接受了两个小时的审讯。起初，他关于克里斯·海曼和约翰·科尔瑟斯特幸存的故事似乎可信。然后，他描述了他开车带两人穿过阿拉斯加的路线。这与该州的地理位置完全不符。警官指控T-Rex谎报案情。他说，如果警察想要进一步的证据，他们应该检查他家沙发垫下面。他们照做了，发现了一本耸人听闻的真实犯罪杂志。杂志上有一篇题为《航行骷髅之谜》的文章，其中包含了大量关于“投资者号”谋杀案的细节。执法部门此前并不知道这些信息不知何故
made available to the media. One of the more popular rumors about the case was that Mark Colthurst had been smuggling cocaine. Interviews with Mark's family and colleagues convinced investigators that there was no truth to this rumor. Mark wasn't the type to get involved in illegal activity. Moreover, there was no way he would risk the lives of his wife and children by bringing them on a drug trafficking operation. Being from out of state, the Colthursts and their crew knew few locals in Craig. Yet, the brutality and concealment of their murders indicated the crime was committed by someone with a personal grievance. Irene Colthurst was described as loving, caring and thoughtful. She helped run Mark's boats with skill while fostering her creative
被提供给了媒体。关于此案最流行的谣言之一是马克·科尔瑟斯特一直在走私可卡因。对马克家人和同事的采访使调查人员确信，这个谣言毫无根据。马克不是那种会参与非法活动的人。此外，他绝不会通过带妻子和孩子参加毒品贩运行动来拿他们的生命冒险。由于是外州人，科尔瑟斯特一家和他们的船员在克雷格几乎不认识当地人。然而，他们谋杀案的残忍和隐蔽性表明，犯罪是由怀有个人怨恨的人实施的。艾琳·科尔瑟斯特被描述为充满爱心、体贴入微。她熟练地帮助经营马克的船只，同时通过制作自己的衣服和珠宝来培养她的创造力
side by making her own clothes and jewellery. Mike Stewart and Jerome Cowan were exceptional university students. Both had taken up fishing in the break between semesters. Chris Heyman had only just finished high school. Dean Moon had been a star footballer in his own school days and was now finding great success in the fishing industry. It seemed unlikely that any of them had been the killer's prime target. This left Mark Colthurst. Unlike the others, he had been shot execution style several times as though the killer harbored deep resentment for him. When speaking of Mark, few had a harsh word to say about him. He was the type of guy others jumped at the opportunity to work with. Mark typically hired young people as he wanted them
一面。迈克·斯图尔特和杰罗姆·考恩是杰出的大学生。两人都是在学期空档期开始捕鱼的。克里斯·海曼刚高中毕业。迪恩·穆恩在学生时代曾是明星足球运动员，现在在渔业领域取得了巨大成功。他们中任何一人成为凶手主要目标的可能性似乎都不大。这留下了马克·科尔瑟斯特。与其他受害者不同，他被多次处决式枪杀，仿佛凶手对他怀有深深的怨恨。当谈到马克时，很少有人对他有恶言。他是那种别人会抢着机会与他共事的人。马克通常雇佣年轻人，因为他希望他们
to make money to continue their education. He was aware that he could catch more with an older, more experienced crew, but Mark didn't care. Though Mark had a good reputation as a hard worker, some found him arrogant and argumentative at times. He had spoken to extended family on the phone hours before his murder, who wished him a happy birthday. As far as they were aware, there were no issues aboard the investor. Mark also hadn't mentioned hiring any new crew. It was clear that the killer was very experienced with boats, particularly with purse senors like the investor. The obvious suspects were the two deckhands whose remains hadn't been found. 18-year-old Chris Heyman was from California. His father owned a marina.
能赚钱继续接受教育。他知道雇佣更年长、更有经验的船员能捕到更多鱼，但马克不在乎。虽然马克作为勤奋工作者享有良好声誉，但有些人觉得他有时傲慢且好争辩。他在谋杀前几个小时曾通过电话与远房亲戚交谈，他们祝他生日快乐。据他们所知，“投资者号”上没有任何问题。马克也没有提到雇佣任何新船员。很明显，凶手非常有船只经验，特别是像“投资者号”这样的围网渔船。明显的嫌疑人是两名遗体未被发现的甲板工。18岁的克里斯·海曼来自加利福尼亚。他的父亲拥有一家码头。
Mark Colthurst had met Chris's dad during a fishing expedition and offered Chris a deckhand position on the investor. It was Chris's first ever fishing job. He was the only person on board who wasn't from Washington. He didn't really have ties to anyone else in the group. 19-year-old Dean Moon had spent the past three fishing seasons working with Mark Colthurst. He was a good employee, having received a promotion and 2% pay rise weeks earlier. But Dean also liked to party. When a previous investor deckhand quit, Dean asked his friend Jerome Cowan to join them. The two friends were seen in Craig hours before the murders and reportedly bought cannabis there.
马克·科尔瑟斯特在一次捕鱼远征中遇到了克里斯的父亲，并为克里斯提供了“投资者号”上的甲板工职位。这是克里斯的第一份捕鱼工作。他是船上唯一一个不是来自华盛顿的人。他与小组中的其他人并没有真正的联系。19岁的迪恩·穆恩在过去三个捕鱼季一直与马克·科尔瑟斯特一起工作。他是一名优秀的员工，几周前刚获得晋升和2%的加薪。但迪恩也喜欢聚会。当之前的一名“投资者号”甲板工辞职时，迪恩邀请他的朋友杰罗姆·考恩加入他们。这两位朋友在谋杀案发生前几小时在克雷格被看到，据报道在那里购买了大麻。
Did this illicit purchase have something to do with the murders? Perhaps Dean was confronted by Mark over the drugs or some other conflict flared up between them. Apparently, Dean Moon owned a gun that he carried on the investor. Investigators considered whether the young man witnessed driving the investor's gift to shore during the blaze was Chris Heyman or Dean Moon. He was described as being in his early 20s, about 5 feet 10 inches tall with a medium build and with blonde or light brown hair that fell below his ears. This loosely matched both Chris and Dean's appearances. Some said the man looked like he had acne. Others remembered him wearing black-framed glasses.
这次非法购买与谋杀案有关吗？也许迪恩因为毒品问题与马克发生了冲突，或者他们之间爆发了其他冲突。显然，迪恩·穆恩拥有一把他在“投资者号”上携带的枪。调查人员考虑了在火灾期间被目击驾驶“投资者号”小艇上岸的年轻人是否是克里斯·海曼或迪恩·穆恩。他被描述为20岁出头，身高约5英尺10英寸，中等身材，留着金色或浅棕色的头发，头发垂到耳下。这与克里斯和迪恩的外貌大致相符。有人说那个人看起来像有痤疮。其他人记得他戴着黑框眼镜。
He was also wearing a baseball cap, rubber boots and either a hooded sweatshirt or fishing jacket. The skiff was seen tied up in Craig on Monday morning, the day before the fire. This was further proof that the murders were committed on Sunday night and the fire was a back-up plan after an attempt to sink the investor failed. Fisherman said they'd noticed the skiff next to the investor at fishing grounds. This hadn't seemed unusual as skiffs were often tied to fishing vessels. The skiff itself was still tied to the docks when investigators went to examine it. By then, it had been there for three days.
他还戴着棒球帽、橡胶靴，穿着连帽衫或渔夫夹克。这艘小艇在周一早上，即火灾发生的前一天，被看到系在克雷格。这进一步证明谋杀案发生在周日晚上，而火灾是试图沉没“投资者号”失败后的备用计划。渔民说他们曾在渔场注意到这艘小艇停在“投资者号”旁边。这看起来并不反常，因为小艇经常系在渔船上。当调查人员去检查时，小艇本身仍然系在码头上。到那时，它已经在那里待了三天了。
Rain had washed it and it had been moved to the dock. Rain had washed it and it had been moved a couple of times by fishermen needing to maneuver around it. Found inside the skiff was a plastic nozzle from a red jerry can, a flat-sided metal container used for transporting liquids, typically water or gasoline. This discovery appeared significant when linked to an encounter reported by a local gas station owner named Jim Robinson. He recalled a short, stocky young man wearing a baseball cap had come into his store carrying a two-and-a-half gallon jerry can. The man explained that he needed some gasoline. Jim told him to go ahead and pump it himself.
雨水冲刷了它，它被移动了几次。雨水冲刷了它，它被需要绕过它的渔民移动了几次。在小艇内发现了一个红色油桶的塑料喷嘴，这是一种用于运输液体（通常是水或汽油）的平侧金属容器。当这一发现与当地一家名为吉姆·罗宾逊（Jim Robinson）的加油站老板报告的一次遭遇联系起来时，显得意义重大。他回忆说，一个戴着棒球帽、身材矮壮的年轻人带着一个2.5加仑的油桶走进他的店里。那个人解释说他需要一些汽油。吉姆告诉他自己去泵。
The man seemed nervous and hyperactive as though in a hurry to leave. He then left on foot and didn't appear to have a car. The investor arsonist would have had to have sourced their own gasoline as Mark Colthurst didn't stock his own. He was considered a real stickler about fire danger. Mark allowed diesel on his boat as it was necessary, but he didn't permit any other type of gasoline, alcohol or propane. He was so cautious he was even reluctant about having cigarette lighters on board. The only way out of Craig was by boat or plane. So if the skiff driver had skipped town, he must have flown or sailed away. Air traffic was temporarily grounded in Craig, but the sea presented a greater challenge.
那个人看起来很紧张且多动，仿佛急于离开。他随后步行离开，似乎没有车。“投资者号”的纵火犯必须自己寻找汽油，因为马克·科尔瑟斯特不储备汽油。他被认为是一个非常讲究火灾危险的人。马克允许船上有柴油，因为这是必要的，但他不允许任何其他类型的汽油、酒精或丙烷。他非常谨慎，甚至不愿在船上放置打火机。离开克雷格的唯一途径是乘船或飞机。所以如果小艇驾驶员逃离了该镇，他一定是乘飞机或航行离开的。克雷格的空中交通暂时停飞，但海洋带来了更大的挑战。
There had been up to 200 boats docked in town. Tracking down potential witnesses and suspects was an enormous and difficult task. Investigators travelled all across America in pursuit of leads. After an extensive search, it became clear. The skiff driver had successfully alluded them. As the first anniversary of the murders approached, the investigative team met in Craig to go over what they knew. They kept coming back to the investor's missing deckhands. Chris Heyman had called home hours before he was killed. He spoke enthusiastically about the trip, telling his mum, it's hard work, but I'm having a really good time. Chris was ultimately crossed off the suspect list. He didn't have the personal connection to
镇上曾停靠了多达200艘船。追踪潜在的目击者和嫌疑人是一项艰巨而困难的任务。调查人员为了寻找线索走遍了美国各地。经过广泛的搜寻，情况变得明朗。小艇驾驶员成功地躲过了他们。随着谋杀案一周年纪念日的临近，调查小组在克雷格会面，回顾他们所知道的情况。他们不断回到“投资者号”失踪的甲板工身上。克里斯·海曼在被杀前几个小时曾给家里打过电话。他热情地谈论这次旅行，告诉他妈妈：“工作很辛苦，但我玩得很开心。”克里斯最终被从嫌疑人名单中划掉。他与
Mark Colthurst that likely motivated the crime. Then there was Dean Moon. He was an experienced fisherman who'd been promoted to the role of skiff man a week or so before the attack, so he definitely knew how to operate the investor's skiff. Plus investigators had received a tip-off that Dean was a heavy drug user who also trafficked. The informant claimed Dean had made frequent drug runs between California and Vancouver. This person also said Dean stole half an acre of cannabis plants and ripped someone else off for $20,000 to $30,000 in cocaine money. A fisherman who'd known Dean Moon came forward to say he'd seen the missing man in early 1983, months after the murders. The fisherman had been at a restaurant
马克·科尔瑟斯特没有可能导致犯罪的个人联系。然后是迪恩·穆恩。他是一位经验丰富的渔民，在袭击发生前一周左右被提升为小艇操作员，所以他绝对知道如何操作“投资者号”的小艇。此外，调查人员收到线报称，迪恩是一名重度吸毒者，也从事贩毒。线人声称迪恩经常在加利福尼亚和温哥华之间进行毒品走私。此人还说迪恩偷了半英亩的大麻植物，并因2万到3万美元的可卡因钱财欺骗了别人。一位认识迪恩·穆恩的渔民站出来说，他在1983年初，即谋杀案发生几个月后，见过这个失踪的人。这位渔民当时在一家餐馆
in San Francisco when Dean Moon walked by the window. The fisherman had previously worked with Dean and was certain he was looking at the same person. Investigators went to San Francisco and headed to Fisherman's Wharf, the area where Dean was allegedly sighted. When shown a photograph of Dean, one person thought they'd recognized him. They said he worked in the nearby coastal city of Monterey. Investigators followed up with Monterey's Fisherman's Association. It was a dead end. Further investigations undermined the informant who'd claimed Dean was a drug trafficker. He had said they went to school together, but he was actually almost seven years older than Dean.
在旧金山，迪恩·穆恩从窗外走过。这位渔民以前和迪恩一起工作过，确信他看到的是同一个人。调查人员前往旧金山，前往据称迪恩被目击的区域——渔人码头。当被出示迪恩的照片时，一个人认为他们认出了他。他们说他在附近的沿海城市蒙特雷（Monterey）工作。调查人员跟进了蒙特雷渔业协会。这是一个死胡同。进一步的调查削弱了声称迪恩是毒贩的线人。他说他们一起上过学，但他实际上比迪恩大近七岁。
They hadn't been students at the same time. It seemed highly unlikely that 19-year-old Dean could have survived on the run for almost a year without reaching out to anyone he knew. It was also widely reported that Dean had idolized Mark Coldhurst, who he saw as a father figure. Mark in turn treated Dean like a son. Dean Moon was ultimately crossed off the suspect list. Investigators were certain that he, Chris Heyman and John Coldhurst all died on the investor. They were all officially declared deceased. When discussing their case notes, investigators mulled over another lead they'd picked up on
他们不是同一时期的学生。19岁的迪恩在逃亡近一年而不联系任何他认识的人，这似乎极不可能。还有广泛报道称，迪恩崇拜马克·科尔瑟斯特，他将马克视为父亲般的人物。马克反过来也像对待儿子一样对待迪恩。迪恩·穆恩最终被从嫌疑人名单中划掉。调查人员确信他和克里斯·海曼、约翰·科尔瑟斯特都死在了“投资者号”上。他们都被正式宣布死亡。在讨论案件记录时，调查人员反复思考了他们收集到的另一条线索
in the early days of the investigation. In the immediate aftermath of the investor blaze, state troopers had walked around Craig on the lookout for anyone who fit the skiff driver's description. They were helped by a local named Jerry Mackie. He was Craig's Village Safety Patrol Officer, a uniformed first responder role created for rural Alaskan communities. As detailed by author Leland Hale, Jerry went to check the local bar as it was a popular hangout spot for fishermen. There were around 10 to 15 people inside drinking. Jerry looked around the room taking in every face. Most of the patrons returned his gaze, but one man quickly looked away. He continued to sneak looks at Jerry and appeared uneasy. Jerry noted that this man looked to be
在调查初期。在“投资者号”火灾发生后，州警官在克雷格四处巡逻，寻找任何符合小艇驾驶员描述的人。他们得到了当地人杰里·麦基（Jerry Mackie）的帮助。他是克雷格的村庄安全巡逻官，这是一个为阿拉斯加农村社区设立的穿制服的急救人员角色。正如作家利兰·黑尔（Leland Hale）所详述的那样，杰里去检查当地的酒吧，因为那是渔民的热门聚集地。里面有大约10到15个人在喝酒。杰里环顾房间，观察每一张脸。大多数顾客回视他，但有一个人迅速移开了目光。他继续偷偷看杰里，显得不安。杰里注意到这个人看起来
around the same age, height and appearance as the skiff driver. Jerry informed the troopers patrolling the area. One fetched Bruce Anderson and Jan Kittleson, the married couple who had first sighted the skiff driver and got the best look at him. The couple were asked to go into the bar one at a time to see if they could identify him. Bruce went in first. He stopped near the entrance, but didn't see anyone familiar. Jan took a little longer walking around to see people up close. She didn't recognize the skiff driver either. Despite this, State Trooper Captain Mike Kolovoski was struck by how certain Jerry Mackey had been. He asked Jerry to point out the suspicious man. He was sitting by windows that overlooked the
年龄、身高和外貌与小艇驾驶员差不多。杰里通知了在该地区巡逻的警官。一名警官找来了布鲁斯·安德森和简·基特尔森，这对首先目击小艇驾驶员并对他观察最仔细的已婚夫妇。这对夫妇被要求一次一人进入酒吧，看看他们是否能认出他。布鲁斯先进入。他在入口附近停下，但没有看到任何熟悉的人。简花的时间稍长，走动着近距离观察人们。她也没有认出小艇驾驶员。尽管如此，州警队长迈克·科洛沃斯基（Mike Kolovoski）对杰里·麦基的确定程度感到震惊。他让杰里指出那个可疑的人。他正坐在俯瞰
street outside. He had a longish, dirty blonde hair and was around 5'10". He certainly had that California surfer look about him. Captain Kolovoski noticed that the man kept looking over at them. When approached, he identified himself as John Peale. He provided a driver's license from the state of Washington. Peale revealed that he'd been friends with the victims of the investor murders. He had previously worked for Mark Colthurst on another boat and had once dated Mark's sister. At the time of the murders, Peale had been stationed on the Libby 8, a vessel tied up behind the investor. He claimed to have been asleep by 6 o'clock in the Libby 8's crew quarters on the night of the killings. The reason he'd gone to bed so early
外面街道的窗户旁。他留着长长的、脏兮兮的金发，身高约5英尺10英寸。他确实有那种加州冲浪者的样子。科洛沃斯基队长注意到那个人一直看着他们。当被接近时，他自称是约翰·皮尔（John Peale）。他提供了华盛顿州的驾照。皮尔透露，他是“投资者号”谋杀案受害者的朋友。他以前在另一艘船上为马克·科尔瑟斯特工作过，还曾与马克的妹妹约会。在谋杀案发生时，皮尔驻扎在“利比8号”（Libby 8）上，这是一艘系在“投资者号”后面的船。他声称在杀戮之夜6点前就在“利比8号”的船员宿舍里睡着了。他睡得那么早的原因是
was because he was stoned. While most who knew John Peale considered him to be a good guy, some described him as untrustworthy. He had a temper and would get a wild look in his eyes sometimes. While working for Mark Colthurst, Peale passed out from inebriation. As a joke, other deckhands tied his hands and legs to a table. When Peale regained consciousness, he started yelling. Dean Moon went to help him as Peale threatened to kick his ass. Peale drew Mark Colthurst's ire by smoking cannabis and drinking beer while on duty. But the final straw was when Peale turned up two hours late one day. Mark fired him.
是因为他当时吸毒了。虽然大多数认识约翰·皮尔的人都认为他是个好人，但也有人说他不可信。他脾气暴躁，有时眼神会变得狂野。在为马克·科尔瑟斯特工作时，皮尔曾因醉酒昏倒。作为恶作剧，其他甲板水手把他的手脚绑在桌子上。当皮尔恢复意识时，他开始大喊大叫。迪恩·穆恩去帮他，结果皮尔威胁要揍他。皮尔因在值班时吸食大麻和喝啤酒而激怒了马克·科尔瑟斯特。但压死骆驼的最后一根稻草是有一天皮尔迟到了两个小时。马克解雇了他。
John Peale maintained that there had been no bad blood between him and Mark. In fact, the Colthursts had bought Peale and his wife a wedding present after his dismissal. Yet Peale was known to angrily complain about Mark behind his back. In July 1982, Peale bumped into Mark in the Alaskan city of Ketchikan. Mark was there with his family and crew on his new boat. Peale asked if he could hitch a ride with them to Craig where he was hoping to find work. Mark told Peale they weren't headed that way, so Peale pawned his watch to catch a ferry to Craig instead. Once there, he was hired to work on the Libby 8.
约翰·皮尔坚称他和马克之间没有积怨。事实上，在皮尔被解雇后，科尔瑟斯特一家还给皮尔和他的妻子买了结婚礼物。然而，皮尔却以在背后愤怒地抱怨马克而闻名。1982年7月，皮尔在阿拉斯加的凯奇坎市偶遇了马克。马克当时正带着家人和船员在他的新船上。皮尔问他是否可以搭他们的便车去克雷格，他希望能在那儿找到工作。马克告诉皮尔他们不去那个方向，于是皮尔典当了他的手表，改乘渡轮去了克雷格。到达那里后，他被雇佣在“利比8号”上工作。
Two months later, the investor arrived in Craig. On the night of Sunday, September 5, 1982, Peale and a fellow Libby 8 crew member named Brian Polinkus went into Craig. According to Brian, they soon came across investor Deccan's Dean Moon and Jerome Cowan. Peale was said to have sold the young men $400 worth of cannabis, though he denied this. Peale and Brian then returned to the Libby 8 for dinner. Afterwards, they headed back out. While in town, Brian looked away for a moment. When he turned back, John Peale was gone. Brian returned to the Libby 8 at around midnight. Peale's bed was empty. John Peale later told Brian that he'd been at his girlfriend's house on the night
两个月后，投资者号抵达了克雷格。1982年9月5日星期日晚上，皮尔和“利比8号”的另一名船员布莱恩·波林库斯去了克雷格。据布莱恩说，他们很快遇到了投资者号上的迪恩·穆恩和杰罗姆·考恩。据说皮尔卖给了这些年轻人价值400美元的大麻，尽管他否认了这一点。随后，皮尔和布莱恩回到“利比8号”吃晚饭。之后，他们又出去了。在镇上时，布莱恩转过头去了一会儿。当他转回来时，约翰·皮尔不见了。布莱恩在午夜左右回到了“利比8号”。皮尔的床上空无一人。约翰·皮尔后来告诉布莱恩，那天晚上他在女朋友家。
of the murders. Although Peale had a wife in Washington, he'd been seeing a young woman in Craig. Peale's story to Brian Polinkus was at odds with what he'd told investigators, that he was asleep on the Libby 8 from 6pm onwards. Investigators followed up with Peale's girlfriend. She said she'd ended things with him months earlier after finding out he was married. Another Libby 8 crew member named Dawn Holmstrom was good friends with the John Peale. She hadn't seen him on the boat on Sunday night or Monday either. But late on Tuesday, she bumped into him in Craig. Peale was wearing blue jeans, a flannel shirt, and blue baseball cap with a cannabis leaf on it that he almost always wore.
谋杀案发生时。虽然皮尔在华盛顿有个妻子，但他一直在克雷格和一个年轻女子交往。皮尔对布莱恩·波林库斯的说法与他告诉调查人员的说法相矛盾，他当时说自己从下午6点开始就在“利比8号”上睡觉。调查人员随后联系了皮尔的女朋友。她说，在发现他已婚后，她几个月前就和他分手了。另一名“利比8号”的船员道恩·霍尔姆斯特罗姆是约翰·皮尔的好朋友。她周日晚上和周一都没有在船上见到他。但周二晚些时候，她在克雷格偶遇了他。皮尔穿着蓝色牛仔裤、法兰绒衬衫，戴着一顶他几乎总是戴的印有大麻叶图案的蓝色棒球帽。
The following day, after news of the investor murders had broken, Dawn saw John Peale again. He seemed fine but expressed disbelief that someone could have killed his friends. Then Peale suddenly said he was scared and started to cry. I can't believe I could have done that, Peale said. It all happened so fast. That same day, John Peale flew home to Washington, though he initially told police he'd left on September 9. According to him, the reason for his sudden departure was that he was going on vacation. First, Peale had to catch a six-seater plane to Ketchikan. It was the last flight that left the island before all air traffic was grounded. Peale spent the flight from Ketchikan to Washington,
第二天，在投资者号谋杀案的消息传出后，道恩再次见到了约翰·皮尔。他看起来很正常，但表示不相信有人会杀害他的朋友。然后皮尔突然说他很害怕，并开始哭泣。皮尔说，我不敢相信我竟然会做出那种事。一切发生得太快了。同一天，约翰·皮尔飞回了华盛顿，尽管他最初告诉警方他是9月9日离开的。据他说，他突然离开的原因是他要去度假。首先，皮尔必须搭乘一架六座飞机前往凯奇坎。这是在所有空中交通停飞前离开该岛的最后一班航班。皮尔在从凯奇坎飞往华盛顿的途中，
drinking and smoking cannabis. Another passenger felt that Peale couldn't wait to get home. He drank so much that he passed out in a bathroom and had to be carried off the plane. Despite having not been ID'd as the skiff driver, John Peale maintained a lingering presence in the investor murders case. At one stage, Mark Colthurst's mother phoned investigators to let them know she'd thought the composite sketch of the suspect resembled Peale. Then investigators received a letter from a man who'd been visiting Craig at the time of the fire. Joe Weiss had gone to Alaska to fish the previous year. On the evening of Sunday, September 5, he'd been at Craig's laundromat.
一直在喝酒和吸食大麻。另一名乘客觉得皮尔迫不及待地想回家。他喝得太多，以至于在洗手间昏倒，不得不被人抬下飞机。尽管没有被确认为小艇驾驶员，但约翰·皮尔在投资者号谋杀案中一直存在嫌疑。有一次，马克·科尔瑟斯特的母亲打电话给调查人员，说她认为嫌疑人的合成素描像皮尔。随后，调查人员收到了一封信，来自一名在火灾发生时访问过克雷格的男子。乔·韦斯前一年曾去阿拉斯加钓鱼。9月5日星期日晚上，他曾在克雷格的自助洗衣店。
He spotted some young men smoking cannabis. Joe would later come to realise that these men were Dean Moon and Jerome Cowan. At 10 o'clock the next morning, one day before the fire, Joe saw a lone man pull up at the dock in what looked like the investor's skiff. He thought nothing of this sighting at the time. A year later, Joe Weiss came across an article about the murders. It featured a composite image of the skiff driver sought by investigators. It looked like the same man Joe had seen in the investor's skiff the morning after the murders. Joe contacted the authorities and was presented with a photographic lineup of six different men.
他看到几个年轻人正在吸食大麻。乔后来意识到这些人是迪恩·穆恩和杰罗姆·考恩。第二天早上10点，也就是火灾发生前一天，乔看到一个男人独自驾驶着看起来像是投资者号的小艇停靠在码头。当时他并没有多想。一年后，乔·韦斯看到了一篇关于谋杀案的文章。文章中刊登了调查人员正在寻找的小艇驾驶员的合成图像。这看起来和乔在谋杀案发生后的第二天早上在投资者号小艇上看到的男人是同一个人。乔联系了当局，并被展示了一组六名不同男子的照片。
He was asked who looked the most like the skiff driver he'd seen. Almost immediately, Joe replied, if I had to pick a most like, I think number three. The man Joe identified was John Peale. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support case file to continue to deliver quality content. Investigators orchestrated for Joe Weiss to go to Washington to ID John Peale in person.
他被问到谁看起来最像他看到的小艇驾驶员。乔几乎立刻回答说，如果非要选一个最像的，我想是三号。乔指认的人是约翰·皮尔。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商的内容来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持案件档案继续提供高质量的内容。调查人员安排乔·韦斯前往华盛顿亲自指认约翰·皮尔。
They casually escorted Joe to the harbor where Peale was in a small boat with a friend. Joe agreed that Peale looked like the man he'd seen in the investor's skiff. State troopers planted stories in the local media, reminding people about the crime and hinting that they were closing in on a suspect. Then they made arrangements to question John Peale. Newspaper clippings about the case were laid out on a table in the interview room. Peale was left alone to take in the site before two troopers joined him. They informed Peale that an eyewitness had identified him as the missing skiff driver in the investor murders case. Oh, you think you got your man, right? Peale asked sarcastically.
他们随意地护送乔来到港口，皮尔当时正和朋友在一艘小船上。乔同意皮尔看起来就像他在投资者号小艇上看到的那个男人。州警在当地媒体上植入报道，提醒人们注意这起犯罪，并暗示他们即将锁定一名嫌疑人。然后他们安排审讯约翰·皮尔。审讯室的桌子上摆放着关于此案的报纸剪报。皮尔被单独留在那里观察现场，随后两名警察加入了他的行列。他们告诉皮尔，一名目击者已指认他为投资者号谋杀案中失踪的小艇驾驶员。哦，你们以为抓到人了，对吧？皮尔讽刺地问道。
He asked what they thought his motive was. It was laid out to him clearly. As a boss, Mark Colthurst could be hard to please and had a reputation for being difficult. Peale had been vocal in his anger about being fired by Mark. Then, when Mark arrived in Craig after refusing to give Peale a lift there, Peale's feelings intensified. On the night of the murders, he headed over to the investor to make amends and wish Mark a happy birthday. But Mark was out with his family. Peale stayed on the boat and drank with Dean Moon and Jerome Cowan, whom he knew and was friendly with. By the time the Colthursts returned, shortly before 10 p.m., Peale was drunk. Mark ordered him to leave. Peale then flew into
他问他们认为他的动机是什么。他们向他明确说明了这一点。作为老板，马克·科尔瑟斯特很难伺候，而且以难相处而闻名。皮尔曾公开表达过对被马克解雇的愤怒。后来，当马克拒绝给皮尔搭便车而抵达克雷格时，皮尔的情绪更加强烈。在谋杀案发生的当晚，他前往投资者号试图和解并祝马克生日快乐。但马克和家人出去了。皮尔留在船上，与他认识且关系友好的迪恩·穆恩和杰罗姆·考恩一起喝酒。当科尔瑟斯特一家在晚上10点前不久回来时，皮尔喝醉了。马克命令他离开。皮尔随后陷入了
a rage and pulled out a gun. It hadn't been his intention to kill anyone, but things spun out of control. Peale listened to the theory before replying. I think you're nuts, man. He repeatedly professed his innocence and agreed to take a polygraph test. The results indicated that Peale was being deceptive. Still, he was released from custody. Investigators felt they had gotten what they needed. A confession. Written transcripts of the interview revealed that Peale had seemingly slipped up. When told he had to make up his mind about what to do next, Peale replied, I'm scared, man. I can't believe the things I did in there. The case finally had some momentum. All the people who had seen the skiff driver were shown
狂怒并掏出了一把枪。他本无意杀人，但事情失控了。皮尔听完了这个理论，然后回答说，我觉得你们疯了，伙计。他反复声称自己是无辜的，并同意接受测谎仪测试。结果显示皮尔在撒谎。尽管如此，他还是被释放了。调查人员觉得他们得到了他们需要的东西。一份供词。审讯的书面记录显示，皮尔似乎说漏了嘴。当被告知他必须决定下一步该做什么时，皮尔回答说，我很害怕，伙计。我不敢相信我在里面做的事情。案件终于有了一些进展。所有见过小艇驾驶员的人都被展示了
photographic lineups. They all picked out Peale's image. This included married couple Bruce Anderson and Dejan Kittleson. The pair had missed Peale when he'd been sitting in the bar in the days after the murder, but successfully pointed him out in the lineup. Out of all the witnesses, only one caught a glimpse of anyone suspicious on the investor the night of the killings. Larry Demet Jr. was the skipper for the Libby 8, the fishing vessel John Peale worked on that was positioned next to the investor. Between 10 and 11pm, Larry sighted a person climbing aboard the investor. In Larry's words, the stranger looked like a dirty old fisherman. Larry woke at around 2am upon hearing something strange. As detailed in author Leland Hale's book,
照片排查。他们都挑出了皮尔的照片。这包括已婚夫妇布鲁斯·安德森和迪扬·基特尔森。这对夫妇在谋杀案发生后的几天里，皮尔坐在酒吧时错过了他，但在排查中成功指认了他。在所有目击者中，只有一个人在杀戮当晚瞥见了投资者号上的可疑人员。拉里·德梅特二世是“利比8号”的船长，这是一艘停在投资者号旁边的渔船，约翰·皮尔就在这艘船上工作。在晚上10点到11点之间，拉里看到一个人爬上了投资者号。用拉里的话说，那个陌生人看起来像个肮脏的老渔夫。拉里在凌晨2点左右听到奇怪的声音后醒来。正如作者利兰·黑尔的书中所述，
What Happened in Craig, Larry didn't say what that something was. All he told investigators at the time was, I felt evil. I felt evil in the air. After speaking with police, Larry drank alcohol where previously he'd abstained. He'd also started taking Valium and carrying a gun. He said he needed it to feel safe. Investigators tried to coax more from Larry. Eventually, he admitted that the real reason he'd woken at 2 on the night of the murders was because he'd heard what sounded like six to eight gunshots followed by a woman's scream. Larry had peered out of a porthole but saw nothing. After a few minutes, he got up and opened the door to his cabin. Looking outside, he noticed a man walking across some neighboring boats. He was wearing a plaid shirt and a blue
《克雷格发生了什么》，拉里没有说那是什么声音。当时他只告诉调查人员，我感到邪恶。我感到空气中弥漫着邪恶。与警方交谈后，拉里开始喝酒，而他之前是不喝酒的。他还开始服用安定并随身携带枪支。他说他需要它来获得安全感。调查人员试图从拉里那里套出更多信息。最终，他承认他那天晚上2点醒来的真正原因是，他听到了听起来像是六到八声枪响，随后传来了一声女人的尖叫。拉里透过舷窗向外看，但什么也没看见。几分钟后，他起床打开了船舱的门。向外看时，他注意到一个男人正走过几艘邻近的船只。他穿着一件格子衬衫和一顶蓝色
cap with a cannabis leaf on it. In his right hand was a rifle. It was John Peale. Larry Demert Jr. was one of many eyewitnesses that implicated John Peale during his murder trial in January 1986. With no physical evidence, the entire case rested on the testimony of the 150 or so people who took the stand. In the words of a memory expert testifying on behalf of the defense, the problem was that human memories are not perfect recordings of past events. They can change and be manipulated over time. The eyewitnesses had not identified John Peale with as much certainty as had been presented. The majority said Peale looked the most like the skiff driver out of all the images in the photographic lineups. Yet none were 100 percent
印有大麻叶图案的帽子。他右手拿着一支步枪。那是约翰·皮尔。拉里·德梅特二世是1986年1月约翰·皮尔谋杀案审判期间指控他的众多目击者之一。由于没有物证，整个案件完全依赖于出庭作证的约150人的证词。用一位代表辩方作证的记忆专家的说法，问题在于人类的记忆并不是对过去事件的完美记录。它们会随着时间的推移而改变和被操纵。目击者并没有像所呈现的那样确定地指认约翰·皮尔。大多数人说，在照片排查的所有图像中，皮尔看起来最像小艇驾驶员。然而没有一个人是百分之百
sure. Some said Peale looked a bit older than the person they'd seen. Others said his hair was a different shade. One lineup included 29 images. Eight were of John Peale. Some were posed, others were candid. A few had been taken from behind a two-way mirror during a police interview. The other photos included missing and declared dead victims Dean Moon and Chris Heyman, as well as some men who looked like Peale but had no connection to the case. John Peale was the only person in the photographs who was wearing a baseball cap, as the skiff driver had been. Under cross-examination, a number of the prosecution's witnesses admitted that they weren't certain Peale was the skiff driver at all. Other witness accounts were weakened
确定的。有些人说皮尔看起来比他们看到的人稍微老一点。其他人说他的头发颜色不同。其中一组排查包括29张照片。八张是约翰·皮尔的。有些是摆拍的，有些是抓拍的。有几张是在警方审讯期间从双面镜后面拍摄的。其他照片包括失踪并被宣布死亡的受害者迪恩·穆恩和克里斯·海曼，以及一些看起来像皮尔但与案件无关的男子。约翰·皮尔是照片中唯一戴着棒球帽的人，就像小艇驾驶员那样。在交叉盘问中，一些控方证人承认他们根本不确定皮尔就是小艇驾驶员。其他证人的证词也被削弱了
entirely. Peale's lawyer also introduced a witness who had seen the skiff driver but hadn't been called upon by the prosecution. This witness said the man had been, quote, a stocky native. Witness Jim Robinson was zeroed in on by the defense. He was the local gas station owner who'd sold a jerrycan of gasoline to a man believed to be the skiff driver shortly before the fire. Jim had been shown the photographic lineups but was never able to identify anyone in them. As the customer he'd served, he changed his mind after seeing John Peale in person at a court hearing. He now claimed that Peale bought the gasoline. It turned out that Jim Robinson was actually a wanted fugitive named Kenneth Robertson.
完全。皮尔的律师还介绍了一位目击者，他见过小艇驾驶员，但没有被控方传唤。这位目击者说，那个人是，引用，一个矮壮的本地人。证人吉姆·罗宾逊被辩方锁定。他是当地加油站的老板，在火灾发生前不久，他卖给了一个被认为是小艇驾驶员的男人一桶汽油。吉姆被展示了照片排查，但从未能从中指认出任何人。作为他服务的顾客，他在法庭听证会上亲自见到约翰·皮尔后改变了主意。他现在声称是皮尔买了汽油。事实证明，吉姆·罗宾逊实际上是一个名叫肯尼斯·罗伯逊的通缉逃犯。
In 1981, a year before the investor fire, Robertson escaped Arizona where he was serving a criminal sentence. Peale's lawyer wanted to question Robertson about his past conviction on the stand saying it was relevant to the case but the judge disagreed. Therefore, the jury wasn't informed that Robertson had been previously found guilty of arson. He'd set a car on fire that belonged to his ex-wife's boyfriend. He'd also threatened to kill an ex and her family with explosives and a sawn-off shotgun. After fleeing Arizona, Robertson managed to live incognito in Craig for a number of years. The jury deliberated for six days but were unable to reach a verdict. Most were in favor of acquitting John Peale, though a few wanted to convict. Realizing they
1981年，即投资者号火灾发生前一年，罗伯逊从亚利桑那州逃走，当时他正在那里服刑。皮尔的律师想在证人席上询问罗伯逊关于他过去的定罪，称这与案件有关，但法官不同意。因此，陪审团并不知道罗伯逊之前曾被判犯有纵火罪。他曾放火烧毁了他前妻男友的车。他还曾威胁要用炸药和短管猎枪杀死前任及其家人。逃离亚利桑那州后，罗伯逊在克雷格隐姓埋名生活了多年。陪审团审议了六天，但未能达成裁决。大多数人倾向于判约翰·皮尔无罪，尽管有几个人想判他有罪。意识到他们
were hopelessly deadlocked, the judge declared a mistrial. There were several key elements of the case that raised serious concerns. Two witnesses who had been John Peale's crewmates on the Liby 8 alleged that investigators had coerced statements from them. One was Dawn Holmstrom, who had spoken with Peale the day after the fire. He had started crying, questioning how someone, quote, could do that to his friends. This part of Dawn's story had changed by the murder trial. She claimed that Peale had actually said, I can't believe I could have done that. Dawn claimed that investigators had threatened and sworn at her until she changed her statement.
陷入了绝望的僵局，法官宣布审判无效。案件中有几个关键因素引起了严重关切。两名曾是约翰·皮尔在“利比8号”上的船员的证人声称，调查人员强迫他们作出了陈述。其中一人是道恩·霍尔姆斯特罗姆，她在火灾发生后的第二天与皮尔交谈过。他开始哭泣，质疑某人，引用，怎么能对他的朋友做出那种事。道恩故事的这一部分在谋杀案审判时发生了变化。她声称皮尔实际上说的是，我不敢相信我竟然会做出那种事。道恩声称调查人员威胁并辱骂她，直到她改变了证词。
Her colleague, Brian Polinkus, made similar allegations about the aggressive nature of the questioning. Then there was the matter of Peale's alleged confession to police. According to the transcript of his police interview, Peale had said, I can't believe the things I did in there. When the defense team listened to a recording of the interview, they heard Peale actually say, I can't believe the things you think I did in there. These issues were raised in a pretrial hearing, though were dismissed by the judge. He didn't think the jury would give much weight to the interview transcript, and disagreed that witnesses had been coerced.
她的同事布莱恩·波林库斯对审讯的攻击性提出了类似的指控。然后是皮尔据称向警方供认的问题。根据他警方审讯的记录，皮尔曾说，我不敢相信我在里面做的事情。当辩护团队听取审讯录音时，他们听到皮尔实际上说的是，我不敢相信你们认为我在里面做的事情。这些问题在审前听证会上被提出，但被法官驳回了。他认为陪审团不会太看重审讯记录，并不同意证人受到胁迫的说法。
But he was concerned when evidence showed that the traces of gasoline found on the investor didn't match the gasoline John Peale was alleged to have purchased. The residue on the boat was from pure white gasoline, whereas the gasoline from the gas station was the regular kind. It was possible two kinds were used and one had burned away, one had burned away, leaving no trace. But the judge still determined that the prosecution had presented this evidence incorrectly. The prosecution remained determined to convict John Peale. Consequently, a retrial was scheduled. It commenced in January 1988. Investigators thought luck was on their side when they found a new witness.
但他感到担忧的是，证据显示在投资者号上发现的汽油痕迹与约翰·皮尔据称购买的汽油不符。船上的残留物是纯白汽油，而加油站的汽油是普通汽油。有可能使用了两种汽油，其中一种已经烧尽，没有留下任何痕迹。但法官仍然认定控方错误地提交了这些证据。控方仍然决心给约翰·皮尔定罪。因此，安排了重审。审判于1988年1月开始。调查人员认为当他们找到一名新证人时，运气站在他们这一边。
Charles Samuelson was a fisherman who John Peale worked for in 1983. Charles said he and his brother had been fishing with Peale one day, when Peale turned to him with a strange smile. He then said, I did it. I killed them. Charles dismissed this as a joke, but it played on him over the years. After the first trial concluded, he decided to come forward. Charles Samuelson had a few misdemeanor charges pending against him. The state agreed to drop these in exchange for his testimony. John Peale's defense attorney revealed the deal to the courtroom to undermine Charles's evidence.
查尔斯·萨缪尔森是一名渔民，约翰·皮尔曾在1983年为他工作。查尔斯说，有一天他和兄弟正与皮尔一起钓鱼，皮尔带着一种奇怪的微笑转向他。然后他说，我做了。我杀了他们。查尔斯认为这只是个玩笑，但多年来这件事一直困扰着他。第一次审判结束后，他决定站出来。查尔斯·萨缪尔森身上有几项未决的轻罪指控。州政府同意以他的证词为交换撤销这些指控。约翰·皮尔的辩护律师向法庭披露了这笔交易，以削弱查尔斯的证据。
His brother, who had also been present for the exchange, admitted that he'd thought Peale's remark was just a joke. Peale's lawyers also attacked witness Larry Demet. The Libby 8 skipper claimed he had heard gunshots on the night of the murders. He later revealed that he'd seen Peale fleeing the investor with a rifle in his hand. Peale's lawyers questioned why it took Larry so long to come forward with such significant information, dubbing him, Last Minute Larry. On the stand, Larry came across as vague and confused.
他的兄弟也曾在场，他承认他认为皮尔的话只是个玩笑。皮尔的律师还攻击了证人拉里·德梅特。“利比8号”船长声称他在谋杀案当晚听到了枪声。他后来透露，他看到皮尔手里拿着步枪从投资者号上逃走。皮尔的律师质疑为什么拉里花了这么长时间才提供如此重要的信息，称他为“最后一刻的拉里”。在证人席上，拉里显得含糊不清且困惑。
His use of valium was scrutinized, while Peale's lawyer suggested he was only testifying to get out of drug charges. But Larry Demet remained adamant that John Peale was responsible for the murders. This time, the jury spent four days deliberating. They found John Peale not guilty on all counts. Having spent the last four years of his life on house arrest, John Peale was a free man. It was one of the only times in US history where a jury had acquitted someone accused of a mass murder. Speaking outside court, Peale remarked, I'd just like to say it's terrible being innocent and being accused of a crime. Thank God it's over, and justice did work this time.
他使用安定的行为受到了审查，而皮尔的律师暗示他作证只是为了摆脱毒品指控。但拉里·德梅特仍然坚持认为约翰·皮尔应对谋杀案负责。这一次，陪审团花了四天时间审议。他们裁定约翰·皮尔所有罪名不成立。在过去四年的软禁生活中，约翰·皮尔重获自由。这是美国历史上陪审团裁定大规模谋杀案被告无罪的极少数案例之一。在法庭外，皮尔评论说，我只想说，无辜却被指控犯罪是件可怕的事。感谢上帝，一切都结束了，正义这次确实发挥了作用。
To John Peale's family in France, his acquittal was vindication. Those closest to him had always insisted that Peale wasn't a violent person and wouldn't so much as punch someone. They described him as a mellow, easy-going person who was polite and hard-working. He had sold small amounts of recreational drugs on occasion but had no serious criminal history. After Peale's initial arrest, a petition asking for the charges to be dropped reached 1500 signatures within days. The families of the victims felt differently. Ruth, the mother of missing crew member Dean Moon, was upset. She'd endured her son's name being dragged through the mud over the years as it was speculated that he was the killer.
对于约翰·皮尔在法国的家人来说，他的无罪释放是一种平反。那些最了解他的人一直坚持认为皮尔不是一个暴力的人，甚至连打人都不敢。他们形容他是一个随和、好相处的人，礼貌且勤奋。他偶尔会卖少量娱乐性毒品，但没有严重的犯罪记录。皮尔最初被捕后，一份要求撤销指控的请愿书在几天内就获得了1500个签名。受害者的家属则有不同的感受。失踪船员迪恩·穆恩的母亲露丝感到很难过。多年来，她忍受着儿子的名字被拖入泥潭，因为人们猜测他是凶手。
Peale's lawyers had even presented Dean as a likely a suspect than their client, despite the teen having been officially declared dead. Ruth had been expecting Peale would be found guilty. Mark Colthurst's parents also believed John Peale was guilty but ultimately accepted the verdict. Quote, We have to basically now work with going on with our lives and put it all behind us. Nothing will bring our children back, and that's just the way it is. Authorities made it clear that they believed a guilty man had gotten away with murder. As far as they were concerned, the case was solved. They just hadn't gotten the outcome they wanted. The state had spent $2.7 million prosecuting John Peale. At the time, it was the most expensive
皮尔的律师甚至把迪恩描述为比他们的当事人更可能的嫌疑人，尽管这名少年已被正式宣布死亡。露丝一直期待皮尔会被判有罪。马克·科尔瑟斯特的父母也认为约翰·皮尔有罪，但最终接受了裁决。引用，我们现在基本上必须努力继续我们的生活，把这一切抛在脑后。没有什么能把我们的孩子带回来，事实就是这样。当局明确表示，他们认为一个有罪的人逃脱了谋杀罪。就他们而言，案件已经破了。他们只是没有得到他们想要的结果。州政府花费了270万美元起诉约翰·皮尔。当时，这是阿拉斯加历史上最昂贵的
case in Alaska's history. Some jurors later spoke out. One explained that there had been a few on the jury who believed Peale was guilty, but the state's evidence just wasn't good enough to support a conviction. John Peale filed a civil suit against the state for wrongful prosecution. He said he'd suffered mental anguish, emotional distress, and a loss of income as a result of the charges. He asked for $177 million, with some to be allocated to his wife, son, parents, and sister. The case was settled for $900,000. In 2017, John Peale spoke to People magazine after long refusing to give interviews. Somebody was responsible for this, he said. Somebody out there knows what happened, but I'm not going to waste any more of my life on it.
案件。一些陪审员后来发表了看法。其中一人解释说，陪审团中有几个人认为皮尔有罪，但州政府的证据不足以支持定罪。约翰·皮尔对州政府提起了错误起诉的民事诉讼。他说，由于这些指控，他遭受了精神痛苦、情感困扰和收入损失。他要求赔偿1.77亿美元，其中一部分分配给他的妻子、儿子、父母和姐妹。该案最终以90万美元和解。2017年，约翰·皮尔在长期拒绝接受采访后接受了《人物》杂志的采访。他说，有人对此负责。外面有人知道发生了什么，但我不会再浪费我的生命在上面了。
Every year on the first Sunday in May, blessings for members of commercial fishing fleets who have lost their lives at sea are held in Blaine and Bellingham, the Washington cities where almost all of the investor victims were from. One of Mark Colthurst's sisters always attends and makes sure to memorialize Mark, Irene, Kimberly, and John Colthurst, as well as Chris Heyman, Dean Moon, Jerome Cowan, and Michael Stewart. The investor murders remains the largest ever unsolved mass murder in the state of Alaska. There is still speculation as to who was responsible. Some are convinced John Peale was guilty. Others believe the drug smuggling theory. It's also been suggested that the culprit and their motives will remain forever unknown.
每年5月的第一个星期日，在布莱恩和贝灵厄姆（几乎所有投资者号受害者所在的华盛顿城市）都会为在海上遇难的商业渔船船员举行祈福仪式。马克·科尔瑟斯特的一位姐妹总是参加，并确保纪念马克、艾琳、金伯利和约翰·科尔瑟斯特，以及克里斯·海曼、迪恩·穆恩、杰罗姆·考恩和迈克尔·斯图尔特。投资者号谋杀案仍然是阿拉斯加州历史上最大的未破大规模谋杀案。关于谁该负责，仍有各种猜测。有些人确信约翰·皮尔有罪。另一些人相信毒品走私理论。也有人认为，罪魁祸首及其动机将永远不为人知。
Whatever the truth, authorities have no intention of reinvestigating the case. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论真相如何，当局都没有重新调查此案的打算。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。